[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Like many
Google Cloud customers,
you probably use the
Global Load Balancing
platform to get benefits like
high availability, low latency,
and the convenience
of a single anycast
IP to front-end your capacity.
But did you know that by adding
Cloud CDN and Cloud Armor
to your existing Global HTTP(S)
load balancer deployment,
you can get faster web
performance and improved web
protection?
In this video, we'll
focus on Cloud CDN.
Cloud CDN runs on our
globally-distributed edge
points to reduce network
latency by caching content
closer to your users.
Whenever a request is served
from the Cloud CDN cache,
the load balancer doesn't
need to retrieve content
from the backend infrastructure.
This allows you to scale
seamlessly and easily
handle large spikes in demand.
Since static web elements such
as images, videos, and more,
can be served from Google's
global edge instead
of your backend
systems, your users
can enjoy faster page loads
and a smoother web experience.
Finally, Cloud CDN helps
you optimize and reduce
the cost of delivery.
It keeps load off
your web servers,
keeping down compute usage.
And content served out
of Google's edge cache
is billed at a
lower egress cost.
Once you've set up an
HTTP(S) load balancer,
Cloud CDN can be enabled by
clicking a single checkbox.
Let's see a quick demo on
how to do this and verify
it's working.
In this Google Cloud
project, I already
have a global HTTP(S)
load balancer set up
with a backend storage bucket.
To enable Cloud CDN to an
existing external HTTP(S) load
balancer, just click Edit
on the load balancer page
and head to the
backend configuration.
Click Edit on your
backend service
and click the checkbox
to enable Cloud CDN.
Select your cache mode.
By default, Cloud
CDN will apply a time
to live to all static content,
such as images, JavaScripts,
and CSS file types.
You can also choose to use
origin cache control settings
or have Cloud CDN override the
and apply a cache
control value regardless
of what the origin headers say.
That's it.
The CDN configuration
options are all
available within the same
workflow of your load balancer
console.
Now click Update
and Update again.
It can take up to
10 minutes to apply.
To validate that
Cloud CDN is working,
we can look at the log lines
that Google Cloud captures.
To do this, you must
first generate requests
to the external load balancer.
We'll head to our
frontend serving our image
from the backend storage
bucket and refresh the page
to generate traffic
to the load balancer.
Now let's head to Cloud
loggings Log Explorer.
We can filter by
our load balancer
and the associated forwarding
rule to our frontend.
We can see our logs.
Logs before CDN enablement show
the JSON payload status detail,
"response sent by backend."
Our most recent log now
shows the status detail,
"response from cache."
Congratulations,
you've just set up
Cloud CDN for your external
HTTP(S) load balancer
on Google Cloud and learned
how to check for cache hits.
To learn more about Cloud CDN,
check out cloud.google.com/CDN.
[MUSIC PLAYING]